you know it's true the holidays can
really be stressful for just about
anyone but if you are caring for someone
with alzheimer's or dementia you
probably feel that stress year round
well caregivers are so often busy
meeting they are so busy meeting the
needs of their loved one that they
neglect their own physical and even
mental health i met a devoted wife who
ignored signs of serious heart problems
until it was almost too late
i knew there was a problem i ignored it
and i'm i think typical of most
caregivers coco and bob hickman spent
much of their 35-year marriage traveling
and chasing adventure but the past 10
years have been a journey the fun-loving
partners never planned on coco has
become bob's full-time caregiver as he's
declined with lewy body dementia we call
him louie third person refer to him that
way
not good
the couple tries to maintain their sense
of humor through this debilitating
disease
bob's vivid hallucinations forced him to
hand over the car keys travel nowadays
consists of routine doctor visits coco
handles his medications his meals bob's
failing memory and all of the household
chores the emotional and physical strain
is constant caregiving is such a time
intensive process and particularly in
the later stages of the disease it truly
becomes a 24 hour seven day a week job
and so as a result caregivers have less
and less time for maintaining their own
health that became all too real for coco
the couple recently moved from las vegas
to washington state to be near family in
case of an emergency and she's glad they
did i had
an issue where i had to be life flighted
to seattle
for heart issues
thankfully they kept me alive until i
got there coco now has a pacemaker but
the outcome could have been very
different dr lucille carrier is a
clinical health psychologist at the lou
rouevo center for brain health in las
vegas she urges caregivers to speak up
and we want you to reach out you may not
know what your needs are you know as
professionals let us help you you know
or talk to another caregiver who's in a
similar place in the journey
bob participates in a weekly virtual
dementia music class giving his wife
some time to herself and coco has joined
a valuable caregiver support group
social connection human connection at
its basic form
is such a vital component along the
caregiver journey to reduce those
feelings of isolation
to reduce burden strain coco says she
now realizes that her own well-being
ensures that she'll be there for bob as
long as he needs her i can't overstate
that because if you don't take care of
yourself you can't take care of them
well coco
also recently just took a much-needed
weekend away with her sister for a break
and a change of scenery dr carrier says
respite for caregivers is incredibly
important here's what else she suggests
reach out to family friends or neighbors
for help so that you can take those
breaks when you need them
make a care plan for yourself along with
your loved one if you're staying healthy
then you'll be able to keep them healthy
as well
connect with people either through a
group or a friend for conversation allow
yourself time to vent and get out that
frustration
stay informed of your loved one's
prognosis so that you can plan ahead and
overcome the fear of the unknown
and also work through your grief the
grief of the loss of your loved one
all great information